الا ليت الشباب يعود يوما بيت شعر قالوا
قلب العتاهيه من قرون وبيعكس هاجس من
وقتها ومن قبلها وحتى لغايه اليوم عايشين
البشر كيف نفضل شباب كيف الواحد ما يعجز
اكثر بيقولوا هذه سنه الحياه وما في شيء
اسمه ايقاف الزمن لكن في رجل ثري بئر
الشركه في امريكا مو مقتنع وقرر انه يحارب
ويصرف الملايين علشان يوقف الزمن او حتى
يرجعه لورا كمان ابراهيم جونسون عمره 45
سنه دفع كثير كثير في السابق ومجهز ملايين
كمان اضافيه هذه السنه علشان يتفعلي
مجموعه من 30 دكتور يعمل له اختبارات
واجراءات طبيه برنامج اسمه
البرنامج عكس عمليات الشيخوخه في كل عضو
من اعضاء برايل وعلى فكره البرنامج متاح
للي يبغى مقابل 1000$ في الساعه حتى اليوم
نتائج البرنامج اللي بتقول انه برايل اللي
بيذكركم ان هو الولد قبل 45 سنه قلب عمره
37 سنه جل عمره 28 سنه همم شكله كده يعني
مشدود مره جلد رئتي عمرهم 18 سنه اما عمره
البيولوجي عموما فهو اصغر من عمره الفعلي
ب 5 سنوات البرنامج علشان يكون واضحين هو
عباره عن مجموعه فحوصات واجراءات طبيه مثل
ما قلنا لكن كمان في التزام من الزبون
ببرنامج واضح وقاسي من الاطباء فبراير
بيتمرن ثلاث مرات بالاسبوع لمده ساعه
تمارين محدده وقاسيه هو كمان ملتزم بنظام
غذائي بياخذ فيه في اليوم 1977 سعره
حراريه مو 2,000 ولا 1,500 لا تحديدا 1977
سعره حراريه والسعرات كلها طبعا بتكون
نباتيه اما بالنسبه للنوم فبينام في نفس
الوقت كل ليله وقبله به للساعتين كامله
لابسه لابس بيكون فيها نظارات بتحجب الضوء
الازرق طبعا كل هذا مخلي عنده الجسم اللي
شايفينو واللي فيه خمسه الى سته في المئه
فقط دهون
الاخبار عن الموضوع طبعا قلبت الدنيا خاصه
لما الناس طلعت ضوء وطلعت صور مو من كثير
زمان يعني الي برايه وصراحه في الفرق واضح
واصلا مجرد فكره الرجوع بالزمن هذه الحاله
كافيه تفتح جدل ونقاشات لكن غير هذا
النقاش بين الناس بين العلماء في انقسام
كمان على الموضوع ففي وقت في علماء
ودكاتره شغالين على المشروع وبيطلعوا
بيانات في علماء ثانيين جالسين بيقولوا لا
ما في شيء زي كده والكلام هذا غير صحيح
وغير علمي عبر الهاتف ينضم الينا دكتور
اشرف الداد رئيس قسم البتولوجيا المناعيه
في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي اهلا فيك
معنا دكتور اشرف خليني اول شيء اسالك عن
هذه البروجكت هل فعلا اللي هو جالس بيسويه
يعني فعلا يرجع الشخص يرجع عمره لوراء
اسعد الله مساك بكل خير سيد الكريمه وعلى
الساده المشاهدين هو حقيقه ما طلعنا عليها
الان من برنامج غذائي زائد يعني تمارين
رياضيه معينه حددت من اطباء متخصصين في
مجال اللياقه البدنيه
هو عباره
عن وليس غير طبيعي من ناحيه الجميع ما
ياخذه همم هذا الرجل الذي يريد ان يصغر
سنه يعتبر شيء طبيعي اخ سواء من ناحيه
الاكل الذي ياخذه الغذائيه التي يقودها او
التمارين الرياضيه الصارمه التي يعني
يعملها يوم يلتزم بها ذلك
بالمنام وكل هذا الكلام
هو معروف ان النوم الصحي يساعد خصوصا في
تحسين البشره
المواد المؤكسده التي تؤثر بطريقه سلبيه
على البشره واذا نام الشخص فان هذه مفعوله
سوف يكون اقل بكثير وكان هذه احد الشروط
طبعا ان يذهب دائما في نفس الوقت الى
النوم وايضا موضوع النظارات التي تحجب
الفلتره والضوء الازرق ايضا ان هي تحجب ال
ال ال العوامل البيئيه السلبيه التي تؤثر
على
الحياه الصحي هو اللي عامله كمان اضافي
موضوع انه عنده فريق الاطباء طول الوقت
بيفحصوا له همم
يعني عمر اعضاء والكلام هذا كله بس هل هذا
فعلا هيقدر يوقف التقدم في الثانيه يعني
هو بيولوجيا اقل من عمره خمسه سنين هل هذا
يعتبر انجاز
اي نعم يجب ان نوضح للجمهور انما يفعله
يعتبر رياضه زائد نظام غذائي صحي ولكن
صارم جدا الان اذا شخص عمره 45 سنه يوميا
يلتزم بنظام صحي او رياضي معين حتما سوف
ترجع رئتيه عشر سنوات او ربما حتى 20 سنه
الى الخلف اذا كان عمره 50 سنه فهذا معروف
الذين الاطباء اذا فحصت الرئتين مثلا بعد
رياضه لمده مثلا لمده سنه سوف تكون همم
تقريبا تشابه يعني سن اقل بخل ب 10 سنوات
وفي المقابل اذا لم تلعب همم تعمل الرياضه
او عملت على الدخان على سبيل المثال
الرئتين سوف تتقدم 20 سنه الى الامام هذه
الاشياء معروفه هي هو ما يفعله فقط نظام
صارم جدا يعني صعب تنفيذه من الناس
العاديين همم لكي يحصل على اكثر مفعول فيه
تصغير ش- سنه وتنشيط همم طيب والفلوس اللي
بيدفعها دي كلها يعني يعني احنا ممكن نعمل
النظام الصحي بس انه اروح ادفع مليونين في
السنه هذه ليش بيدفعها بس عشان متابعه
الاطباء
نعمته المشكله الاولى طبعا العامل المادي
الذي لا يستطيع اي شخص طبعا همم
توفيره او الحصول عليه والشغله الاخرى
النظام الصارم الذي حسب ما طلعنا عليه سبب
عنده اضطرابات نفسيه كبيره يعني هذا الرجل
همم يعني صعب ان تذهبي فان كل يوم في نفس
الموعد
وتاكلي نوع معين فقط من الاغذيه همم ولا
يجب ان ترتدي بهذا النوع فهذا طبعا صعب
جدا هذه العاملين اعتقد همم صعبين جدا
ولهذا لا يطبق على العامه ما يفعله هذا لا
يطبق على همم
ولكن في نفس الوقت يعني موضوع التقدم في
السن والامور هذه كلها في دراسات صارت
كثير جلسه بتصير على هذه
المواضيع وخصوصا في الفتره الاخيره كان في
تقدم في هذه الناحيه هل في خيارات او طرق
اخرى غير اللي هو بيعملوا
نعم هذا سؤال مهم اعتقد ان العيش الايجابي
جدا في هذا الخبر انه يعني يعمل على الاقل
توعيه للناس لكي يعيش بطريقه صحيه يعمل
الرياضه ويوجد طرق اخرى طبعا اسهل من هذا
النظام الصارم ولكن في بدايتها وهي اييه
ما يسميها بالانجليزي
تغيير ال ال الجينات التي تسبب اكسده
الجسم ويعني شيخوخه الجسم
وتحسين يعني البشره وتحسين عمل الاعضاء عن
طريق تغيير الجينات وهذا ما يعمل الان ما
يعمل عليه العلماء
يعني ولا ناخذ حبوب ولا ايه نعملها
عن طريق ادويه ادويه ياخذها الشخص وتغير
مثلا حمض اميني معين يكون مسؤول عن انتاج
اكسده زائده يعني والاكسده غير سلفيه
تعتبر من الجسم وخصوصا شيخوخه الجسم وشارك
كبير خصوصا ان هذا الموضوع الان يصرف عليه
وليس البلايين همم
عشر سنوات القادمه سوف
نوع من الادويه التي تؤدي الى الاقل يعني
تحسين
الجسم واعضائه الفزيولوجيه
يعني الاعمار بيد الله يعيش بصحه جيده
وبنشاط جيد جدا ما يقدر نحنا بنشكرك على
هذه
المداخله والتوضيحات كان معنا عبر الهاتف
دكتور اشرف الدادر رئيس قسم البتولوجيا
المناعيه في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]